[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
صواريخ الفصائل تصل وسط اسرائيل وتل ابيب
تتوعد بمزيد من الاغتيالات في غزه
الغاضب يؤكد نجاح اوكرانيا بالهجوم المضاد
وتراجع الجيش الروسي
من تفشي الملاريا والحصبه الى حمى الضنك
السودان يعاني والصحه العالميه تحذر من
سوء التغذيه
في تركيا محرم انجي زعيم حزب البلد يرفع
الرايه البيضاء وينسحب من السباق
الانتخابي قبل ايام من الاقتراع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه تطورات متسارعه
يشهدها تصعد الحاصل في غزه مراسل العربيه
افاد بتنفيذ الطيران الاسرائيلي غارات على
القطاع مشيرا الى ان دفعه جديده من
الصواريخ اطلقت من غزه على مستوطنات
الغلاف واتت هذه التطورات بعد مقتل
اسرائيلي واصابه اربعه اخرين بعد سقوط
صاروخ مباشر على مبنى في منطقه روحوبوط
جنوبي تل ابيب وذكرت تقارير الاسرائيليه
ان صاروخ اطلق من غزه وكان متوسط المدى
وخلف اضرارا واسعا
و
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من على حدود قطاع غزه معنا زياد حلبي مدير
مكتب العربيه في فلسطين زياد اهلا بك هل
هناك المزيد من الصواريخ التي وصلت الى
العمق الاسرائيلي
هناك غارات تشنها اسرائيل تباعا في في
قطاع غزه في عشرين دقيقه الاخيره في شمال
قطاع غزه كان هناك غارات وايضا في منطقه
حي التفاح بغزه ايضا كان هناك غارات
الصواريخ الاخيره كانت قبل حوالي ساعه من
الان الى غلاف قطاع غزه مجددا ايضا كان
هناك استهداف لمنطقه ريشون
جنوب تل ابيب وسط اسرائيل في هذه المناطق
لن يكون هناك فتى افتتاح للمدارس يوم غد
بسبب الاستهداف الصاروخي المتكرر
عمليا
المشاورات الامنيه التي اجراها نتنياهو
انتهت على الاغلب ستواصل اسرائيل محاولات
الاغتيال الليله
لكوادره من الجهاد الاسلامي بالاضافه الى
الغارات عمليا بعد الرشقات الصاروخيه
الاخيره التي اطلقت نتحدث عن اكثر من 700
صاروخ منذ بدايه بدا حمله التصعيد
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه نعم طيب ولكن
زياد يعني عمليه استهداف القيادات في
الجهاد الاسلامي بالتحديد او سياسه
الاغتيالات كما تسميها اسرائيل يسقط معها
العديد من الضحايا من السكان الذين يسكنون
بجوار هؤلاء القاده كيف تتعاطى السلطات
الاسرائيليه مع هذه الانتقادات
جلما عمليا تقتلهم اسرائيل لهم ليسوا من
الجهاد الاسلامي في نهايه المطاف هي
اغتالت سبعه من القاده واكثر من عشرين
فلسطينيه عمليا
سقطوا في هذه
الاستهدافات المتكرره من الجيش الاسرائيلي
لكن بدون ادنى شكل الان هناك معضله امام
الاسرائيليين في هذه النقطه الزمنيه
الحساسه جدا مع الحديث عن تعثر وقفه اطلاق
النار والمفاوضات وما الى ذلك معضله
بنيامين نتنياهو والمؤسسه الامنيه الان هل
تستمر اسرائيل في هذا الموضوع ما قد لا
يبقي حماس خارج الصوره نسبيا لانها شاركت
ولكن ليس بكامل قوتها هذا اكيد وان دخلت
حماس في هذه المواجهه ستصبح حربا شامله
نعم طيب هل الصاروخ الذي وصل الى روحه
جنوبيه تل ابيب وادى الى مقتل اسرائيليه
على ما اعتقد واضرار كبيره في المبنى هل
هذا الصاروخ وهذا الوصول الصاروخ الى هذا
المدى يجعلنا امام احتماليه كبيره ان
تتحول المواجهه الى حرب مفتوحه
هناك طبعا
امكان ان يتحول تتحول الى ذلك كما كنت
اشرح قبل قليل فقط عندما تدخل حماس عمليا
وباقي الفصائل بقوه اكبر واوسع هذا يقودنا
الى مواجهه ربما من اسابيع ولهذا اقول
بانه حتى عند الحديث عن تعطر وقف اطلاق
النار قد يكون هذا الامر مؤقتا غدا قد
تسمع حديثا مختلفا ايا كان بدون شك لدى
الجهاد الاسلامي قدرات صاروخيه معروفه
للاسرائيليين لديه صواريخ باليستيه
استخدمها اطلق على
اعتراضته اسرائيل بواسطه مقلاع داود
منظومه لاول مره تستخدم عمليا في تاريخ
اسرائيل الاعتراض صاروخ باليستي بهذا
المعنى اليوم كانت هناك حصيله حصيله تدمير
واستهدافات يعني غير مسبوقه في الفتره
الاخيره داخل اسرائيل نتحدث عن 19 مصابا
عمليا عن مقتل مستوطن عن اصابه منازل
مباشره في مستوطنه وحدها عمليا وهناك كان
حادثا ايضا كان ليكون دراماتيكيا جدا
استهداف بالقرب من سياره وزيره الاستيطان
اريد ستروك عمليا اصيبت سيارتها بشظايا من
هذا الصاروخ الذي انفجر على مقربه منها
بينما كانت في مستوطنه بهذا المعنى هناك
يعني تطورات متلاحقه اطلاق دفعات من
الصواريخ وهناك غارات واستهدافات
اسرائيليه هذا سيستمر اقله حتى الغد شكرا
جزيلا لك زياد حلبي مدير مكتب العربيه في
فلسطين كنت معنا من حدود قطاع غزه
اذا اسرائيل تمضي قدما في هجماتها ضد حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي بقطاع غزال موجه الاخيره
لا تزال تحصل الضحايا من بين قياديين
الحركه القوات الاسرائيليه شنت غارات جويه
على غزه ادت الى مقتل القيادي في حركه
الجهاد احمد ابو دقه وفق ما ذكرته رويترز
ومن جهتها اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
عن اصابه اربعه اشخاص في الغارات
الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
ولا يبدو بان اسرائيل عازمه على ايقاف هذه
الحمله حيث تستعد لاطلاق المزيد من
الصواريخ هذا ما اكدته صحيفه تايمز التي
نقلت عن مكتب وزير الدفاع
توجيهه لتعليمات للجيش بالتحضير لسلسله من
العمليات الاضافيه ضد قطاع غزه والاستعداد
لاطلاق صواريخ على نطاق اوسع اما نتنياهو
فاعلن ان بلاده لا تزال في وسط العمليه
العسكريه سواء في الهجوم او الدفاع مشيرا
الى ان اسرائيل سترد على مطلقي الصواريخ
ومن يحل محله
سكان
سابق من صباح اليوم قمنا باغتيال قائد
مجموعه صواريخ الجهات في غزه والان منذ
فتره وجيزه اختل نائبه ايضا اي شخص ياتي
ليؤذينا لن يجني سوى الدم على راسه هو ومن
يحل محله نحن في منتصف المعركه في الهجوم
والدفاع وسنواصل التقدم لحمايه سمائنا
وحياه مواطنين
نتابع من قطاع غزه مع الصحفيه روانه
صوراني روان اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه
حصيله الغارات الاسرائيليه على القطاع حتى
الان
يمكننا القول ان غزه تعرضت في الساعات
الاخيره لموجه مكثفه من الغارات من قبل
الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي طالت شمال وسط
وجنوب القطاع يعني من شده الغارات
وتتابعها يصعب علينا حصرها بالتحديد ولكن
اللافت ان الاستهدافات لا زالت في اطار
الاراضي الزراعيه والذي تقول اسرائيل
بانها تتبع لي مواقع عسكريه لسرايا القدس
من مراصد
ومقدرات
صاروخيه بحث ارضيه اسرائيل ووافقه وسائل
الاعلام
قالت بانها حتى اللحظه استهدفت 191 هدفا
في قطاع غزه هذه الاهداف تتبع لي فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وعلى راسها الجهاد
الاسلامي وذراعه المسلحه
سرايا القدس بالتالي يمكننا القول بان ما
كان مامولا بالامس من الوصول الى ساعات
لتهدئه ولوقف لاطلاق النار تحول في هذه
الى موجه عارمه من اتساع دائره النار
ودائره اللهب خاصه مع
وصول الساعه التاسعه اليوم وهذا يذكرنا
بما جرى بالامس الساعه التاسعه اليوم
وسرايا القدس خاطبت الجمهور وطلبت
في الساعه التاسعه للتهليل والتكبير شهدت
قطاع غزه انطلاقا لمجموعه كبيره ساسالك عن
البيان المصور لما قالته حركه الجهاد
واحاديثها على وصول صواريخها الى اسرائيل
لكن دعيني اسالك اذا كان هناك اي موقف من
حماس او اي فصيل فلسطيني اخر خاصه حماس
اذا كانت ستدخل ايضا هذه المواجهه الى
جانب الجهاد الاسلامي
لو سمحتي يتعلق بالبيان الاخير لسرايا
القدس اكد في الناطق باسم سرايا القدس
باننا مستعدون لتوسيع الدائره النار وبان
الاغتيالات لن توقف المقاومه ايضا الغرفه
المشتركه لفسائر المقاومه كان لها بيان
قالت فيه بان اسرائيل اخطات في استهدافها
لي منازل المواطنين وبان يد المقاومه كما
جاء في البيان الثقيله قادره على ايلام
العدو في العمق كما ورد في بيان الغرفه
المشتركه لفصائل المقاومه روان نصراني من
غزه شكرا جزيلا لك
ووسط هذا التصعيد المستمر لا يزال التعثر
عنوان المساعي الساعيه للتوسط من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار وتقود القاهره مساعي التهدئه
التي لم تكلل بالنجاح لحد الان وفي اطار
هذه المساعي دائما وصل رئيس الدائره
السياسيه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي محمد
الهندي الى القاهره لبحث الوصول الى اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار وتشترط حركه الجهاد
الافراج عن جثمان خضر عدنان الذي توفي في
السجون الاسرائيليه ووقف الاغتيالات فضلا
عن الغاء مسيره الاعلام المقرره في
الثامنه عشر من مايو المقبل في القدس على
الطرف الاخر فان مطالب اسرائيل ليست واضحه
لحد الان علما ان وفدا مصريا في طريقه الى
تل ابيب ايضا لاجراء مفاوضات بشان وقف
اطلاق النار وذلك نقلا عن هيئه البث
الاسرائيلي
معنى من عمان محمود الهباش مستشار الرئيس
الفلسطيني ساعات المستشار اهلا بكم معنا
في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نقلت عن مسؤولين اسرائيلي بارز قولها ان
القصف على غزه سيستمر اذا استمر اطلاق
القذائف على اسرائيل هل ترون نهايه لموجه
التصعيد هذه ام نحن امام مواجهه مفتوحه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
هذا العدوان اسرائيل الذي الذي بداته
اسرائيل هي التي بدات بهذا العدوان
باغتيال مواطنين من قطاع غزه تقول انهم
قاد في الجهاد الاسلامي او في غيره من
الفصائل
واليوم عندما يكون هناك رد
ونوع من المقاومه من الجانب الفلسطيني
اسرائيل تريد ان تقول انه الهدوء بالهدوء
ووقف النار بوقف النار من الذي بدا هذا
العدوان الذي بداته هي اسرائيل ولذلك نحن
نخشى ان اسرائيل تريد ان تصدر ازماتها
الداخليه هذه الحكومه اليمينيه المتطرفه
تريد ان تصدر ازماتها الداخليه التي
تعيشها من خلال الدم الفلسطيني من خلال
سفك الدم الفلسطيني وكانه هذا الدم هو
الذي سينهي ازمات الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وسيجمع الجمهور الجمهور الاسرائيلي حولها
نحن اولوياتنا التي نعمل عليها والتي يعمل
عليها الكل الفلسطيني وتعمل عليها الاطراف
العربيه
المنخرطه في محاوله وقف هذا العدوان
الاولويه هي لوقف العدوان نعم
لماذا حتى الان
عذرا على المقاطعه لماذا لم تفلح الوساطه
المصريه حتى الان في وقف اطلاق نار مع
العلم ان يعني المساعي كانت حثيثه يعني من
قبل الوسيط المصري
لان اسرائيل باختصار تريد ان تظهر في صوره
المنتصر المنتصر صحيح تريد وقف اطلاق
النار يظهرها امام جمهورها بصوره المنتصر
وكانها دخلت معركه حقيقيه وانتصرت في هذه
ليست معركه حقيقيه هذا عدوان من جيش مدجج
باعتى انواع الاسلحه على شعب اعزل على
مدنيين كل الذين سقطوا بفعل هذا العدوان
الاسرائيلي سواء في قطاع غزه او في الضفه
الغربيه كل الذين يسقطون هم مدنيون
فلسطينيون يواجهون اله حرب همجيه ارهابيه
شرسه مدججه بكل انواع الاسلحه ولذلك
اسرائيل لا تريد وقفا لاطلاق النار او
وقفا للعدوان لا يظهرها في صوره المنتصر
وبالتالي هي التي تجهض
محاولات التهدئه وهي التي تفشل كل الجهود
التي تبذل سواء من مصر او من غيرها من اجل
وقف هذا العدوان نعم طيب ساعه المستشار
غرفه الفصائل فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
المشتركه قالت في بيان لها انها لن تتراجع
ولن تزيدها الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه الا
قوه لافته الى ان يد المقاومه الثقيله
قادره على ايلام اسرائيل
هل ولكن هناك راي يقول هنا انه مدام انه
انت امام قوه كبيره قادره على تنفيذ هذه
الاغتيالات واسقاط عدد كبير اخر من
الابرياء الى جانب استهداف القاده بهذه
الاغتيالات فلماذا يكون
استفزاز هذه القوه المدججه بالسلاح كما
وصفتموها
من الذي بدا الاستفزاز اذا اردنا ان نقرا
المعادله بشكل صحيح من الذي بدا الاستفزاز
الذي بدا الاستفزاز في شهر رمضان المبارك
هو الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على المسجد
الاقصى هو الاغتيالات التي وقعت في الضفه
الغربيه في جنين ونابلس وغيرها هي
الاعتداءات الاستيطانيه اليوميه من قبل
المستوطنين ومن جيش الاحتلال على
المواطنين في القدس وفي الضفه الغربيه هي
محاوله خنق قطاع غزه من خلال الحصار ثم
جاء بعد ذلك او اتت اسرائيل بعد ذلك
بالهجوم الذي نفذته فجر الثلاثاء على
مساكن مدنيه قتلت من خلاله نساء واطفال
تحت زعم وذريعه انها تريد اغتيال قاده
عسكريين الذي بدا هو اسرائيل والذي يبدا
العدوان دائما هو اسرائيل وردود الفعل
الفلسطينيه مهما كانت صغيره او كبيره لا
احد من حقه ان يلوم رد الفعل على اذا اراد
احد ان يلوم احدا فعليه ان يلوم البادئ
بالعدوان والبادئ بالعدوان هنا هو اسرائيل
شكرا جزيلا لكم الاستاذ محمود الهباش
مستشار الرئيس الفلسطيني كنت معنا من عمان
ومع كل جوله تصعيد بين اسرائيل والفصائل
الفلسطينيه في غزه يسقط عدد كبير من
الضحايا الابرياء كثير منهم يرحلون تاركين
خلفهم قصصا حزينه وذكريات وهذه قصه دانيه
التي قتلت مع شقيقتها وهي تستعد ليوم
زفافها القريب
بدلا ان تزفل عريسها بعد شهر حملت نعشا
الى مثواها الاخير
في هذا البيت انهارت الجدران والاحلام
قتلت دانيه وشقيقتها بصاروخ اسرائيلي وظل
خطيبها محمد باكيا على احلام ورديه دمرت
ومستقبل لن يتحقق ابدا
ايش بدنا نعمل بعد ما يتجوز ايش بدنا نبني
بدي اجيب لها ارض بدنا نحوش خلص
انا واياها خططنا اشياء كتير مع بعض
انا
الذنب وذنبها بنفس الوقت يعني خدوها مني
هي ايش عملتوا او انا ايش عملت
والد العروس علاء شعبان فقد ابنتيه ويحاول
مسانده صهره على ركام منزله في منطقه
الشعف شرق مدينه غزه
لقيت البنت حامض
ودمها
هي حرام
هذا الاحرام
واختها التانيه تحت الردم
تحت الفرشه وهذا الاحرام الثالث تبعها
قتلت اسرائيل اكثر من عشرين فلسطينيا خلال
الساعات الماضيه
بعضهم كان مستهدفا واخرون انتهت حياتهم
ودمرت احلامهم بلا ذنب او تهمه سوى ان هذه
الصواريخ اخطات هدفها
[موسيقى]
والى الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا والبدايه
من الحرب الكلاميه التي يشنها قائد مجموعه
فاجنر
ليصنع الحدث من جديد من خلال تصريحات
مثيره حول التطورات الميدانيه
عن ان الهجوم المضاده الاوكرانيه لا ينطلق
قريبا واعتبر زعيم مجموعه فاجنرال ان
الوحدات الاوكرانيه بدات بالفعل هجومها
المضاد لا سيما في محيط باخموت واطرافها
المثير في كلام بريجوجن هو اعترافه بنجاح
العمليات الاوكرانيه جزئيا على حد وصفه
كما اقر ان قوات كييف الحقت هزيمه ساحقه
بوحده من الجيش الروسي قرب ضخمه
بالنسبه للهجوم المضاد يخادع الهجوم
المضاد يمضي بسرعه وعلى قدم وساق تهاجم
وحدات من الجيش الاوكراني محور باخموت
وللاسف هم ينجحون بذلك كما ذكرت مرات عده
فان خطه القوات الاوكرانيه تتمحور في
خنقنا نحن نحاول خنقهم وهم يحاولون كذلك
هم يحتاجون اولا الى التخلص من عناصر
فاجنر في محور باخموت ثم التوجه بكامل
الامكانيات الى زباروجيا وبريانس وبيل
جورود ولذلك فان الهجوم الاوكرانيه بدا
لقد حصلوا بالفعل على المعدات العسكريه
اللازمه وعلى التدريب اللازم عناصر فاجنر
تواصل مهامها القتاليه رغم عدم وجود
الذخائر والدعم الذي وعدت به وزاره الدفاع
وبموازاه حرب الدبابات والصواريخ المستمره
على ارض المعركه في اوكرانيا تطل الحرب
الكلاميه اذا بين مسئولي الجانبين حرب
كلاميه يحاول فيها كل طرف اظهار تفوقه على
الاخر لكن وفي تصريح النادر ولاول مره منذ
بدايه الحرب الاوكرانيه يعترف الكرملين
بصعوبه هذه العمليه العسكريه التصريح نقله
المتحدث باسم الكرملين الذي اكد في مقابله
تلفزيونيه ان العمليه العسكريه ستستمر رغم
صعوباتها
وصعوبه العمليه العسكريه تجسدها ايضا
تطورات المعارك في اوكرانيا فالى جانب عجز
موسكو عن السيطره الكامله على باخ مط رغم
مرور اشهر من القتال في المدينه تراجعت
سيطره الجيش الروسي على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه فنقلا عن موقع وورما المختص في
رصد مناطق سيطره كل طرف في الحرب فان
الجيش الروسي يسيطر على نحو 16% فقط من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وذلك الى حدود شهر
ابريل الماضي وهو ما يشكل تراجعا واضحا
بالمقارنه مع الفتره التي ثلاث انطلاق
العمليه العسكريه حيث كان يسيطر على نحو
25% من الاراضي الاوكرانيه في مارس 2022
ومن دون شك فان صعوبه مهمه الجيش الروسي
تعود بالاساس الى المقاومه القويه التي
واجهها من الجيش الاوكراني المدعومي
بالاسلحه الغربيه وفي جديد الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا اعلنت الحكومه البريطانيه عزمها
ارسال صواريخ من طراز الى اوكرانيا لتكون
بذلك اول دوله تزود كييف باسلحه بعيده
المدى واكد وزير الدفاع البريط ان امداد
هذه الصواريخ سيعطي اوكرانيا قدرات اكبر
للدفاع عن نفسها في مواجهه روسيا روسيا لم
تتاخر في الرد على هذه الخطوه البريطانيه
حيث اعربت على اللسان المتحدث باسم
الكرملين عن رفضها الشديد لقرار لندن
بامداد صواريخ بعيده المدى الى
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه مستمره بعد قليل من تفشي
الملاريا والحصبه الى حمى الضنك السودان
يعاني والصحه العالميه تحذر من سوء
التغذيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد فاتوره الحرب تبقى
باهظه مهما اختلفت سياقاتها والحال لا
يختلف في السودان التي تعيش وطاه الحرب
منذ ازيد من 25 يوما الخطر المحدق بالبلاد
الان في ظل استمرار المعارك هو امكانيه
تفشي الاوبئه فمنظمه الصحه العالميه دقت
ناقوس الخطر بخصوص الوضع الصحي في السودان
محذره من تفشي الملاريا وحمى الضنك
والحصبه في البلاد الامر لم يتوقف عند هذا
الحد بل نبهت الى ان ملايين الاطفال
والسيدات الحوامل يعانون من سوء التغذيه
الحاد وكشفت المنظمه ان 70% من المنشات
الصحيه في المناطق المتاثره بالقتال بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع خرجت عن
الخدمه ما يهدد بانهيار القطاع الصحي في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
بارقه امل تلوح في الافق من جده السعوديه
حول امكانيه وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
مصادر الدبلوماسيه كشفت للعربيه فان طرفي
الصراع سيوقع عن اتفاقا مبادئ بين الطرفين
يلتزمان من خلاله بهدنه انسانيه هذه انباء
تعزز التصريحات الاخيره للناطق باسم
العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف عن اقتراب
مساعي مباحثات جده من ان تكلل بالنجاح
بدورها كانت وكيله وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه فيكتوريا نولاند قد كشفت بان
المفاوضين الامريكيين المشاركين في
محادثات جده يشعرون بتفاؤل حذر
فما الذي يتضمنه اتفاق اطلاق وقف اطلاق
النار في حال التوصل اليه اذا بهذا الخصوص
كشفت تسريبات من مفاوضات جده عن بنود
الاتفاق المبدئي والتي تشمل ايقاف القصف
الجوي وعوده قوات الطرفين الى مراكزهما
هذا الى جانب انسحاب كل القوات المسلحه
للطرفين من العاصمه ويتضمن الاتفاق ايضا
التزام الطرفين بفتح الممرات الامنه
لافساح المجال لعمليات الاغاثه كما يقضي
الاتفاق المبدئي ان تتواصل المباحثات بين
الجانبين بمشاركه القوى المدنيه وذلك من
اجل الوصول الى اتفاق نهائي
[موسيقى]
في رقم قياسي جديد وصل عدد النازحين حول
العالم الى 71 مليون نازح اضطروا الى ترك
منازلهم قصرا يعود هذا لزياده الصراعات
والحروب والكوارث الطبيعيه وفق تقرير امم
الظرف ذاته والطريق ربما مسيره النزوح عن
الديار تتلاقى تفاصيلها عالميا جلب ما
تيسر لهم ووسيله نقل ان توفرت
اعداد النزوح وصلت مداها عام 2022
وتخطت 71 مليونا في رقم قياسي جديد
ازمه تتبع اخرى عام فتح ذراعيه اما للحرب
او الكوارث الطبيعيه العاملين الاساسيين
لزياده اعداد الفارين
ارتفاع بنسبه 20% بعد هجره جماعيه ضربت
اوكرانيا في حربها بلغ عددهم 17 مليونا
وايضا فيضانات باكستان اغرقت البلاد
بثمانيه ملايين نازح داخليا
العام الماضي ولا ثقيلا على افريقيا
الصراعات المتتاليه ضاعفت اعداد المغتربين
قصرا افريقيا جنوب الصحراء الاكثر تضررا
وصلت اعدادهم الى 16 مليون و500 الف شخص
10 دول اخرى يرزخ فيها ثلاثه ارباع الفرين
داخليا ابرزها سوريا وافغانستان واليمن
واثيوبيا وفق تقرير مشترك لمنظمات امميه
عداد الفرين لن يتوقف وفق تقديرات امميه
هم متقارب ينتظرون فرجا لم ياتي قريبا
ربما في عام حالي بصراعات متفاقمه غذاء
السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى ملف الانتخابات التركيه حيث قال مرشح
وانتخابات الرئاسه محرمه انجا انه قرر
الانسحاب من السباق ويعد انجا واحدا من
اربعه مرشحين للرئاسه الى جانب اردوغان
وكمال وسنان اوغان وقالت وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه ان هذه الخطوه قد تمهد للمعارضه
الفوز من اول جوله وكان استطلاع رايا سابق
يظهر ان اردوغان يتخلف عن
اكثر من خمس نقاط مئويه
[موسيقى]
ومرشح رئاسه تركيا المعارض كمال كلتش
دارولو اسم اتفقت عليه احزاب عده ليس ثقه
به بل رغبه في ازاحه اردوغان عن كرسي
السلطه نتعرف على هذه الاحزاب واهميتها في
هذا العرض للزميله روان حمزه
في السباق الرئاسي التركي اقتصر المشهد
على متنافسين رئيسيين هما الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان والمعارض كمال كالجدار
اوغلو لم يسبق ان اعتبر كلجدار اوغلو محطه
امال المعارضه لكنه استطاع في النهايه
الانتصار بالقبول به كمرشح مشترك التفاف
لم يكن برضى الاغلبيه لكنه تم رغبه من
احزاب المعارضه بمواجهه اردوغان فاضطرت
لتوحيد صفوفها بتجمع سته احزاب تحت ما سمي
الطاوله السداسيه قبل ان تعيد تسميه
التحالفها تحالف الامه بقياده كلجدار
اوغلو صاحب الكتله الاكبر في البرلمان
وزعيم اكبر تحالف معارض كلجدار اوغلو لم
يفوز باي انتخابات ضد اردوغان منذ تولي
الاخير السلطه عام 2002 وواجها ضغوطا
لثنيه عن الترشح للرئاسه رغم ذلك وجدت
المعارضه نفسها مضطره للقبول بالامر
الواقع لهدف واحد الاطاحه باردوغان تغيير
النظام السياسي اداره اقتصاديه مختلفه
جذريا والاهم تبني نهج مختلف كليا عنه في
السياسه الخارجيه
اختيارك الجدار اوغلو مرشحا مشتركا بعد
خلافات عميقه قد يهدد بتفجير ازمات في اي
لحظه لذا سيجدار اوغلو نفسه امام صراع
قديم جديد فحلفاء اليوم هم اعداء الامس
القواعد الحزبيه المحافظه الداعمه له
السعاده الديمقراطيه والتقدم المستقبل
لديها عداء تاريخي ما احزاب اليسار ممثله
بحزب الشعب الجمهوري ورئيسه
اعداءه كالجدار اوغلو ليسوا فقط من احزاب
المعارضه لكنهم داخل حزبه خسرته
للانتخابات الرئاسيه قد تفجر غضبا عارما
وتتسبب بتفتت اصوات المعارضه خاصه وان كل
جدار اوغلو حاول ان يتقرب من المحافظين
رغم ايدولوجيا الحزب العلمانيه وضم
بقوائمه حلفاء السابق لاردوغان امر اثار
حفيظه قواعد حزبيه معارضه واثار مخاوف من
تاثير سلبي على المعدل التصويطي للحزب
وحظوظ الطاوله السداسيه
وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اجراها الزميل
طاهر بركه مع زعيم حزب الوطن اليسري
التركي دوجو برينجيك اكد فيها بان اردوغان
مضطر لان يكون مع اسيا والصين وروسيا
وايران ودول العربيه وانه لا يملك سبيلا
غير ذلك
تركيا اردوغ تركيا تسير وراء قياده
اردوغان ولن تخرج عن مسارها ابدا واردوغان
مضطر ان يكون مع اسيا ومع الصين وروسيا
وايران والدول العربيه ولا سبيل امام
اردوغان سوى هذا
وطاهر بركه موفد العربيه الى اسطنبول معنا
الان مباشره من هناك طاهر اهلا بك في
اخبار الساعه يعني باقي ثلاثه ايام على
الانتخابات الرئاسيه ولدينا مرشح من
المرشحين ينسحب هو محرم انجا لماذا انسحب
انجا وكيف كانت ردود الافعال حول هذا
الانسحاب في هذا الوقت القريب من موعد
الاقتراع
تمام صهيب غير في كثير من المعادله
الانتخابيه في كثير من اجزائها هذا
الانسحاب الذي بدانا ببعض اطرافه نتحدث
عنه بالامس من حيث الموضوع وهو نشر الصور
والفيديوهات التي يقول هو انها مسربه يقول
اليوم انه انسحب لانه تعرض لضغوط شديده
لمحاولات اغتيال سياسيه كما يسميها لتشويه
السمعه وان السلطات التركيه لم تدافع عنه
متهما تنظيم فتح الله جولين الذي يصفه
بالارهاب بهذه التسريبات وعلى فكره معظم
الصفحات التركيه تذكر بحادثه شبيهه مسابقه
عندما اطيح بدنيس بايكال من قياده حزب
الشعب الجمهوري ليحل محله لاحقا في قياده
الحزب كمال كليتشدار اوغلو ويقولون بانه
هذه طريقه فتح الله جولن في التعامل مع
الامه اذا
هذا سؤال كبير بانتظار يوم الانتخابات
ولكن بعض التحليلات واستطلاعات الراي تقول
انه ذلك تلك الاصوات سته تشتت هو طبعا
قاعدته علمانيه تابعه لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
لانه منشق عنه وكان مرشح رئاسيا سابقا
وحصل على الكثير من الاصوات على نسبه
كبيره من الاصوات ولكنه كان مدعوما بتحالف
الان يخوض الانتخابات لوحدها بعض الاصوات
قد تذهب فعلا الى حزب الشعب الجمهوري وقد
تؤدي او تسهم في فوز ربما ان فازك لتشدار
اوغلو ولكنه مرشح لا تعطيه استطلاعات
الراي كثير من الارقام يعني بحد اقصى
اثنين بالمئه وهذا الموضوع ايضا يحصل او
قد يحصل مع مرشح اخر هو سنان اوغان تقول
او قالت بعض المعلومات اليوم غير المؤكده
التي نفاها لاحقا سنان اوغامي بانه قد
يتوجه الى اعلان سحب ترشح ايضا
عزز تلك التوقعات هو يعني اعلان وقفه لبعض
الان الانتخابيه وذهاب الى انقره غدا وهو
اكد انه ذاهب الى انقره ولكن قال مستمرون
في نضالنا ولكن لا تستحق
طاهر يعني المرشحان الرئيسيان البارزا في
هذه الانتخاباته طبعا اردوغان وكل جدار
اوغلو عن هذين المرشحين ارجو ان مثلا وعد
بمضاعفه رواتب الموظفين الحكوميين كذلك
هناك وعود بالتخفيض التضخم من قبل ما هي
نقاط قوه وضعف الرجلين اردوغان وكل طاهر
هذه نقاط مهمه جدا تثيرها صهيب ولكن فقط
دعني اشير باختصار شديد الى رد الفعل
الاساسي من كليتش على انسحاب محرم انجا
دعاه بعد انسحابه الى العوده الى الطاوله
السداسيه قائلا له لنترك خصوماتنا جانبا
ونحاول ان نفعل شيئا
نعم ان ينضم الى الطاوله السداسيه تقصد
تماما
العوده الى الطاوله السداسيه التي تدعم
التي يعني احد مخرجاتها كانت ترشيح كما
بتحالف الامه ولكن من اتهمك
فبركه فيديوهات محرم انجي روسيا بتغريدتين
باللغتين التركيه والروسيه روسيا قائلا له
اصدقائي الاعزاء ان كنتم تريدون يوم
الخامس عشر من مايو اي بعد يوم من
الانتخابات وفي هذا الثقه كبيره بالنصر ان
تستمر العلاقات جيده فعليكم ان تسحبوا
ايديكم من الانتخابات التركيه هذا باهم رد
فعل عن محرم انجي وانسحابه اما بخصوص نقاط
القوه ونقاط الضعف نقاط القوه عند اردوغان
قد يكون بعضها سيف ذو حدين يعني وجوده في
السلطه لمده عشرين عاما وجوده في الدوله
قد يقوي من امكانياته ولكن قد يضعف في
جانب اخر لانه جيل كامل لا يعرف الا
اردوغان وفوزه الانتخابات المتتاليه وهذا
يضعف عند الشباب هو يحاول دائما اشتذاب
هذه الشريحه شريحه الشباب التي يعني تقول
الكثير من التح والمعلومات ومن نتحدث
اليهم الى انهم باتوا يميلون اكثر الى
محاوله التغيير والى دعم كليتش دار اوغلو
القاعده المحافظه طبعا نقطه قوه اساسيه
عند اردوغان اما القاعده العلمانيه فنقطه
قوه اساسيه عندك في موضوع الاقتصاد هذا
عامل سلبي جدا طبعا بحكم ما حصل في
الاقتصاد التركي في السنوات الاخيره
وتراجع الليره وارتفاع التضخم عامل نقطه
ضعف عند اردوغان وقد تكون نقطه قوه عندك
لانه يسهر على المعارضه كما تعرف عندما
تكون خارج السلطه ان تنتقد وان ترفع الصوت
بانتظار ان تحاول التغيير هذه هي المعادله
الاساسيه في نقاط الضعف ونقاط القوه عند
الرجلين المتنافسين الاساسيين في هذه
الانتخابات نعم بانتظارها في الرابع عشر
من مايو بعد ثلاثه ايام تقريبا شكرا جزيلا
لك طاهر بركه موفد العربيه الى اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
المحكمه العليا تامر باطلاق سراح عمران
خان على ايام مجددا امام محكمه اسلام اباد
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد امر في المحكمه
الباكستانيه باطلاق سراح رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان وقالت المحكمه العليا ان
اعتقال عمران خان لم يكن قانونيا وان عليه
المثول مره اخرى امام محكمه اسلام اباد
العليا
المشاهدين قبل ان نتابع نتوقف مع الخبر
العجل الذي ورد قبل قليل مصادر للعربيه
تؤكد على ان هناك توقيعا على اتفاق مبادئ
اولي بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع في
جده طبعا لوقف اطلاق النار اذا الجيش
السوداني الان وقوات الدعم السريعي يؤكدان
في اعلان جده التزامهما بالسياده السودان
ووحدته يبدو ان لدينا اخبار مبشره اذا من
مفاوضات جده او محادثات جده بين ممثلي
الجيش والدعم السريع في جده السعوديه يبدو
ان هناك اتفاقا اوليا على وقف اطلاق النار
حسب مصادر العربيه نوافيكم بالمزيد من
التفاصيل حول ورودها استعدت لاجهزه
الامنيه الامريكيه لاستقبال المهاجرين من
الحدود المكسيكيهم لاربعه وعشرين الف عنصر
وذلك عقب رفع الاجراءات عن قانون
المثير للجدل الذي اقره الرئيس الامريكي
السابق بحجه محاربه انتشار كورونا
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت لي هذه الليله شكرا
لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما على
العربيه على صفحتنا على مواقع التواصل الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات